jodie squeeze aujourd'hui on se retrouve
sur futures self un site qui permet de
se voir dans 20 ans voilà voir si on a
priori éviter par exemple
et comment ça va alors faire quoi la
photo sera prise automatiquement aller
au plus tard c'est trop bien fait et
voilà à tanger pas de résultats à soi
c'est total ont bien fait sous c'est
totalement nul au sexe sommes quand même
merde tu reconnais la petite bande
d'ados montre moi mon avenir ça fait un
choc
haaretz enfin les expressions de dieu
tout de suite ça suffit c'est moi enfin
toi dans 20 ans quoi ah ben il a droit
aussi bien moi c'est plus se
décomposeront fait une bonne blague
mais pourquoi t'es peut-être un petit
peu de gentils quoi faire pour étouffer
ce acte élèves là par contre c'est un
progrès eh ouais et ouais vous l'avouer
c'est carrément scandaleuses que ça fait
quoi fin de la conversation ne me fait
pas ce genre sale [ __ ] adorent dit en
face colas pas du tout avec vivant et si
on fait une tête sérieuse genre vraiment
très sérieuse voilà on est bien là
regard il a tout détectée elle et moi
c'est belle gueule de con est-ce que 20
ans plus tard c'est toujours une belle
gueule de kohat
ça fait un choc as well as tu sais quoi
est ce qui s'est passé les paupières tu
as tu rougis
c'est la chirurgie mais là c'est
complètement à aucun moment on reconnaît
quoi ce mec là pour être j'ai pas
hollande dont 60 ans on y croit il n'y a
pas de problème je suis sûr que même
jumbo et mieux vit avec moi en fait
oh les pauvres dans 20 ans il sera mort
au terme de ces sondes n'ont pas évident
il a détecté et vie [ __ ] et vit avec
des poils il est la jumbo bomba baikeli
enfin et vbi poil mieli quoi regarder
ces jobs ou qu'on voulait plus un jeu
sans les normes oms temps où la wii aux
élèves chélation pilosité quoi c'est
vraiment on dirait un début de l'épreuve
de les pros ce point lui est dû à quoi
ressemblera guen dans 20 ans au non mais
faut que je remette tous les points quoi
le truc chiant j'aime ça avant des
devoirs mais c'est qu'on laisse comme ça
mais cela ça ne saoule de toute faite
par michel hallot le futur appel
oui mais le passé veut pas répondre aux
futures quinn qui fait la grimace ça
marche ou pas retenu moi j'avais pitié
le coc attend le peuple à des aliens qui
naissent dans sa tête la même c'est
incroyable ce site doit pas quand ça
marche c'est un peuple fou quoi ça
marche pas c'est encore plus bluffant
est ce que ça marche
est-ce que ça oh ouais mais à tort au
but fatale rigoles ou quoi
pourquoi les points ça va partout mais
par contre pour lui aucun problème quoi
ya pas de sourcils donc faudrait retirer
ses curseurs la sexe
ah bah on sait pas trop à quoi tu sais
le vif le plus à vous prenez un bordel
plus c'est l'absence totale de lèvres
mais c'est un peu nul quand même là ils
auraient ils auraient pas gagné casting
pourra dans harry potter avec cette tête
quand même comment sera youtube dans 20
ans à quoi ressemblera cyprien sous son
plus beau profil ou la rdl fait un rush
de cheveux dégueulasse tout grâce la
olalala pas rebondir et les pointes de
jumbo qua non mais fait un effort de
détection au [ __ ] ou là oh là là non
mais là on a juste que quand ce week-end
elle avait une photo imprimée sous la
peau mais c'est très troublant on n'en
pâtissent pas surtout qu'au niveau des
yeux faisait rire d'accord il fait ce
cas là je dirais que c'est le vrai
cyprien qui est imprimée sous labro qui
bouge ses yeux que à quoi ressemblera
norman attend celui là tout était
parfaitement quoi ou là haut
mon dieu ça mais c'est clairement pas
normal voire même c'est clairement pas
normal
elles sont les boucles est déjà dans un
premier temps à 6 ans nationaux quand
même autre de rides du front on peut
observer effectivement deux petites
bouclettes qui se battent à quoi
ressemblera nattes ou d'en attendre on
va dire est que des papilles quoi dans
20 ans du ca
non mais regarde mais c'est quoi cette
bouche quoi on dirait qu'elle a faim
organique et la fusionner avec son
déconner c'est dégueulasse là tu vu n'as
tu vu on a tous vu rôle au fait
messieurs reste maintenant le tour 2007
je veux apporter cette image dit vick le
truc me dis aucun visage par contre pour
importer voldemort qui lui n'a aucun
visage hâlé aucun problème donné
un pain
amara
non il ya là la gare rien de chez les
sources il ya les sources et à ces aides
c'est malsain c'est malsain parce que ça
me ressemble un peu rien n'est fait oui
c'est moi allez allez au mec c'est
dégueu la ccfl grave j'en peux plus je
ne veux pas de ce futur et l'agencé dia
fin de cette vidéo sur futur chef ségol
assez marrant comme principe de soient
recomptés vieux même si c'est buggé 18
fois sur 19 a fait ce n'est pas une
élève de ça vous a plu encore merci à
julien qui va penser ceci pour te
retrouver dans une prochaine et les eaux
calmes en bis